you went to a peaceful protest on
January the 6th which was not connected
to the riot everyone involved in that
and that was the moment when things went
out there was hundreds of articles I
think in papers across the globe that
placed me in the headlines at you know
at the at the scene of this this crazy
event which I don't support it you know
I don't I don't I wouldn't storm the
Capital One if I'm not an idiot my label
said we won't be working with uh Ariel
pink anymore from here on out I pretty
much found out that way I believe that
there was an actually there was a behind
the scenes there was actually a an
agreement behind the elitist or the
moneyed interests that basically a round
table that said we will not allow any
kind of positive
speaking of Donald Trump it's do you
think a lot of the strength that you're
feeling is because you lament an America
that no longer exists
yeah in a lament a career that no longer
exists as well I'm just trying to
explain why I think they would want to
destroy someone like of course of course
because they've been brainwashed because
they don't believe in countries because
they don't believe in money because they
don't believe in borders because they
want to destroy the they don't believe
in a country those people should not be
eligible to be president
foreign
[Music]
old wallets giving you a bulge where you
don't want it to be my old wallet was
massive so it brought all the ladies to
the yard which was a huge distraction
and got in the way of my esteemed work
on trigonometry reg wallets have an
incredible solution for you this is mine
Sleek stylish and with an industrial
look to it can fit 12 cards with cash on
the back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
I've got one Francis has one even our
producer Anton has one but he's from
Liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about Ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life Rich are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallet
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because Ridge is such
great guys they're going to give you
free worldwide shipping and returns to
take advantage of this incredible offer
go to ridge.com forward slash trigger
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is an
iconic musician whose career took a
dramatic turn where he attended a
peaceful rally in support of President
Trump on January the 6th he was not
involved in the riot in the capital but
his career took a dramatic turn anyway
Arrow pink welcome to trigonometry
thanks for having me uh did I I got your
intro right I think the facts we got in
there we're going to talk about all of
that before we do uh tell our audience
who may be familiar with their work but
many won't be who are you how are you
where you are what has been the journey
through life that leads you here to sit
and talking to us about this
um well uh I've I have I've I'm an indie
musician an indie uh uh I guess uh yeah
I started in the
started in the 90s but I started in
Earnest professionally in 2004 and uh
I've had uh
a
very
steady
sort of a sense it's just been very slow
no billboard uh hits or anything like
that but
um yeah it's been a It's been a
a blessing to be able to do what uh what
I'd love to do and um and I haven't had
to uh uh sell my soul or anything like
that I mean you're being
uncharacteristically modest for an
American as well in that you know you've
collaborated with some incredible people
you're described as the Godfather of
several genres of music like you've had
a pretty stellar career I mean yeah I
mean I'm not I'm but I'm but I'm I
definitely uh uh don't see it that way I
mean I see it as a privilege to work
with these people and and uh uh I just
think of myself as being a very lucky
person which is why I was you know a
patriot in the first place so
if I could make it
in my own little way I feel like
everybody can so
um and you did make it and you were
doing really well I made it enough but I
didn't make it good enough to get myself
out of the mess that I found myself in
right
um
uh but uh yeah so my my career was going
swimmingly
um you know with with the odd Hiccup and
uh you know uh you know season of Bad
press here and there I mean there's been
haters since the beginning that's part
and parcel of my whole appeal is sort of
like just people just didn't like me
since the beginning that's perfectly
fine because I wasn't
made to I wasn't an acquired taste this
I suppose
um but um but yeah nobody was ever uh
you know uh felt uh you were never gonna
make a lot of friends
by being an arrow pink fan I think it's
sort of like you know appeal to
individuals in their groups and their
friend groups and it was always like you
know oh do you like that guy
uh uh you know that's like that's the
friend and that's the one person in the
friend group who likes that you know and
then maybe they'd see some other people
that are like them at the concerts or
something like that I don't know it's
hard for me to like you know
uh wrap my brain around what my appeal
is and and and and who's listening and
who isn't all that kind of stuff so I
kind of don't like to like they even
think about that well whoever it is that
these people who like your stuff exactly
irrespective of that you had a great
career yeah and uh we'll talk about
President Trump and and why you why you
supported him and all of that uh the
thing that I want to get to quite
quickly is you went to a peaceful
protest
on January the 6th which was not
connected to the riot everyone involved
in that
and that was the moment when things went
South
right yeah well I mean uh for me they
went South the next morning that's yeah
I imagine so so what happened tell us
yeah so okay I I uh I hopped on a a
flight last minute with uh with my buddy
and fellow musician John Mouse
um we both wanted to go uh show our
support there seemed to be a feeling
that we should go
um because we because uh well I'm not
gonna I'm gonna speak for him but I was
definitely
pro-trump and uh um
why were you pro-trump what why were you
probably Trump area well that's that's
uh do you want me to get there yeah
let's get to that in a second yeah sure
so we got there and um you know 9 at 9
A.M on the day of the rally which is
what we were there for uh it was
basically like a concert basically like
you know with with uh with queue lines
and everything like that you know at the
Capitol it's very structured yeah there
was their security there but there was
also a a a you know
more or less free for all of you know
just basically like gaggle of people you
know there's a 500 000 people or
something like that I don't even know
how many people were there but it looked
like it was a lot and uh it was a very
very um energetic
uh not unruly
uh crowd of people you know mostly white
all that kind of stuff but there's like
you know the odd
there's lots of people there but I'm
just giving my impressions of it so um
uh but it was it was it was uh people
that were basically
um
that liked him a lot like we needed like
I did so
uh it was cool to see what I noticed was
that there weren't any um
there weren't any like uh
news Vans or anything like that or any
reporters at that event really there
were some in the in the uh
the bleachers where they were kind of
like you know filming him but but there
was no
there's no uh journalists or anything
like that you know on the scene you know
kind of like you know there's no like
bands on the lawn or like you know
basically people like reporting on it so
I thought it was I thought that was very
strange and I made a mental note of it
uh
otherwise it just seemed like it was you
know just a huge population of people it
was like a lot of people there
that were going from the White House
lawn all the way past the Washington
Monument and
just just didn't just didn't mass and
um
that was done there were around around
noon I think is is when when he was done
and I said you know I stuck around
the entire time I got lost from John and
my friends uh Alex Lee Moyer so I was
basically like you know kind of like
half-heartedly listening to his speech
when he gave it and it was kind of like
a there was like a multi-tiered event it
was like you know like there was an
opener there was there was a Donald Jr
was was performing that day too and uh
and uh so was Giuliani and all this kind
of stuff and it seemed like it was like
a big uh a big rah-rah raw Fest you know
it was almost like you know almost uh
almost childish childishly uh uh
jubilant in that kind of sense
and um and there was there was talk that
people were going to go you know
afterwards or or at some point they were
going to go to the Capitol and there's
going to be some sort of like other
protest at some point which I to me it
was like I saw the I already came I say
came to see the main show like I already
saw it I can go home now I mean I don't
need to go to a protest that's boring
yeah so so
um afterward after after this ended uh
we went to the hotel
uh to meet you know sort of rendezvous
with all my all the people that I wanted
to see
we were ended up in a hotel room we took
a few shots
of us just hanging around and hanging
out in the in the hotel room
and uh and I pretty much saw them off
you know I said I'm gonna stay back you
guys I mean I'm just I'm gonna I'm kind
of tired I'm just my day's done
uh like I can die now happy you know
um and uh and so yeah so then I you know
I I quickly you know shuffled off to bed
uh
they went out they came back they woke
me up I said
how'd it go guys and then they're just
like who's cool you know some people got
in or whatever I was just like okay
great I didn't didn't miss anything
thank goodness I knew
but there was no there was no indication
that there was any kind of uh
I didn't I wasn't even aware of any kind
of
uh uh
chaotic exchange or anything or anything
like that was out of the ordinary the
rest of the day
I spent uh you know trying to hail a cab
you know back to the Airbnb with with
John and we were just kind of like ended
up just walking the whole way
just walking through town there was no
there was no uh
feeling of uh of emergency or any kind
of uh
uh just you know chaos or anything like
that on the streets it was just
basically a normal day
so yeah so uh so then we went back to
the uh to the Airbnb and um you know we
didn't really we I can't even remember
what we did we just basically turned on
the TV and just kind of like you know
they hadn't keep in mind they hadn't
called the
but Mike Pence hadn't called the
the election yet you know he basically
hadn't called the count or whatever or
confirmed it or anything so
so there was no reason to
expect that
there was any kind of I wouldn't have
even occurred to me that there would be
a coup because it was too early for that
you know uh I thought that that that
might happen maybe I would imagine
after something was called in you know
against you know in if the election is
called in favor of Biden and then people
and then then you imagine that yeah I
mean maybe maybe they were holding maybe
people were holding on to a chance that
maybe like he wasn't going to call it
like that one so I wouldn't expect them
to to Riot beforehand you know right uh
so um that night
um I think uh I got uh a few tweets uh
or direct DMs
sent to me and uh is the first stirring
of what was to come I suppose
which I didn't even understand was
really the case I mean I guess there was
like somebody that like uh probably
fancied themselves as a
reporter
for you know from Italy or from Verizon
I don't even know where they are where
they're from but but they were just like
what are you doing there
are you know are you there for real and
like I thought it was like it was a word
got out well it's weird as well I didn't
get one sighting on the street nobody
recognized me and I didn't feel like I
was
worthy of being recognized among these
people so um
so I very happily just like I said yeah
I'm here to support the president blah
blah blah now
little did I know that that was that was
what was what had been stirring and with
the narrative that had been sort of uh
sort of Taken taken shape in the
mainstream media
it really I think it really happened
overnight really in uh was uh that this
was an Insurrection that this was like a
a disaster of the dark you know of the
biggest proportions known imaginable
I didn't even know that they were
referring to anything that happened at
the Capitol I thought like you know I
wouldn't have said I was yeah I'm there
yeah I was there you know I mean it was
just it seemed like it was just so
leading the questions were just like why
are you there I'm like I'm in DC to show
my support for the president it just
sounded like I was just basically like
you know just to just
standing you know like piling
uh but uh
but yeah no I mean uh I didn't even know
until
7 A.M the next morning the you know
there was hundreds of articles I think
in papers across the globe
that placed me in the headlines at you
know at the at the scene of this this
crazy event
which I don't support it you know I
don't I wouldn't store the capital I'm
like I'm not an idiot
uh
anyway
um
but you know what you know and I and I
feel for the people that actually just
you know got
got sucked into it I mean it doesn't
take that many people to just sort of
like you know do something start
something and then a bunch of people
just basically follow suit you know so I
I feel like it's you know it's it's a
shame that there's a
that there there's people that uh that
have been sitting there in jail for
for as long as I have uh without any
kind of uh
real trial
but anyway
um so yeah so then so
the next morning I was uh you know uh
texting with my record label and they're
just like you know um they're like I'm
so pissed what are you why didn't you
tell us
and I mean I'm just kind of like why
didn't I tell you what what are you
talking about
and like you could have told us
could have told us that you were going
and I was just like
I mean it still wasn't clear to me what
the what the whole thing was I wasn't
like listening to to the mainstream
media I was just getting my stuff
together and about to leave I don't know
sorry to interrupt I'm really interested
in everything you're saying a lot of our
audience would be quite politically uh
they'd consume a lot of media they'd be
aware of what's going on in politics
what you're saying about this part may
seem almost beyond belief that somebody
wouldn't realize how significant that
was it's it's but you're not actually
that interested in politics are you I'm
not a politically applicant no I had
that not at all I've never I've never
voted this is the the only election that
I ever tried to vote for vote in was
well that there's two there's a there's
uh I think it was a
Nader um I voted for him
never voted for anybody after that so
and then uh and then yeah and then I
voted in 2020. uh but uh but I didn't
vote so you were genuinely unaware that
you got you going to a trump even a
trump rally would actually because
forget about the quote-unquote
Insurrection there are a lot of people
to whom attending a trump rally for a
musician would be seen as controversial
oh and and I mean but I don't hang out
with those people I mean as far as I
know yeah I mean I mean like you know
controversy yeah I'm just a little
surprised that you were surprised that
your label would would would text you
that well I'm surprised because not two
days prior to that like you know we were
we were talking uh I mean these guys are
people that that know me supported me or
had my back
I've been pro-trump uh in I was never
shy about it
although I think people probably thought
it was trolling at first
um
you know when people don't take me
seriously when I say anything really so
uh which is fair enough
um but uh
but really it was uh you know we we had
spoken not not a week prior to to to to
my going there and and they had given me
the reassurance that they you know that
they would never have any issue with my
right my freedom to actually
new vote for the guy you know we can
disagree on it and all that kind of
stuff and we we it was it was totally
civil there was never any kind of like
you know we never were at blows with
each other I mean I don't I don't
believe in that I was just you know just
call me a contrary you know I I have my
reasons for why I voted for him and I
should be able to do that even if I have
no reason to vote for him that's pretty
much how I feel about it fair enough so
keep going keep going so so but all of a
sudden they were kind of like uh
they had they had the the tone changed
and and it was like I had done some
extremely bad thing and that that was a
huge misstep basically they got
inundated with the cancel mob and they
basically had to field it and they were
you know they they they were so angry
about it that they had to basically find
a you know an outlet or they had to
blame it on somebody
and they think that you know the the
best
person to point to was me because it was
I was the headline so
obviously like I must have like you know
tripped their wires and basically done
something to uh to invoke the Wrath and
that's that's you know it was a big
graph and I
I couldn't have been more uh unaware of
it so
um from my perspective it was very kind
of
oh well you guys are you guys are
low lives if you if you think I mean why
don't you call me why don't you talk
about it why don't you ask me what's
going on what happened you know what you
know they didn't even bother doing that
they basically were immediately
down my throat and and then and then not
just them but my friends
every literally everybody that I that I
had in my circle who was basically you
know who
knows my feelings mind you and they they
never give me any indication that that
politics would ever be uh
stick to the point
so there's no reason for me to actually
in in my mind there's no there's there's
nothing to to you know if people want to
say like how could you not know and how
could you think that like it was okay to
vote for this guy well nobody that I
know was ever telling me otherwise
nobody was telling me that like you know
our friendship was was on the on the
Rocks because of it
and in fact I've had nothing but
enthusiastic people that thought you
know that that were mildly amused by it
um and I for all I knew that they felt
the same way and or not you know but I
was oh I was just used to I was happy
with with the fact that like I was the
only person in Hollywood that pretty
much
was outwardly pro-trump that I thought
that was pretty amusing and a pretty uh
pretty strange I mean I feel like I'm
like more famous for that than anything
I've ever done in my career
which is odd it's not you know I've
grown up in Hollywood and and there's
always
some some
conservatives and some some uh
there's always like you know a few
Republicans in in Hollywood that you
know but it didn't seem to matter in the
past so
people didn't didn't have to be
secretive about it and uh there was you
just you just didn't know what people
really who they voted for but you it
really didn't matter because it's one of
the other and
we got along there's never a problem so
for me I didn't you know I there was
something unique about
about the environment or the the sort of
the cultural climate that that was that
made me want to actually vote this time
so it was obviously something that I was
aware of that you know like there was
just there seemed to be a very
um a psychology that was descending on
people that I knew that I felt like I
needed you know I needed to
to do something about or like stand up
in some sort of way uh
and say something about because
I didn't like cancel culture I didn't
like what it was doing to people that I
knew
uh and and I didn't like the the
way it made everybody so feeble
and almost didn't made everybody uh a
passive enabler
by by virtue of the fact that like
nobody could do anything about it so
basically everybody just sort of folded
to it and so and I thought that this was
a very weird phenomenon because it
seemed to me that it was almost illegal
in some sort of sense like it I'm
surprised it never happened prior to
that
it just seems like you know why didn't
this come up
any at any other time in my life
then I feel like we've had protections
uh
in place to to guard against that in the
past and somehow those protections
actually got like
got Stamped Out or ignored
and are not being exploited by
by I think it's just it's kind of too
big to fail kind of mindset that's
basically like taken over everything and
it's taken over the legal system too
well I know Francis wants to ask you
about Trump and all of this other stuff
but just to wrap up this part of the
story January the 7th 2021 you wake up
you have these conversations with your
label how quickly do you then find that
you basically don't have a career
anymore uh within 24 hours I I got uh
I saw that there was a statement that
went out on Instagram
that said uh you know my label said uh
um
we won't be working with uh
Ariel pink AKA Ariel Rosenberg
anymore from here on out so so I uh
I pretty much found out that way wow and
uh without without a phone call without
anything and uh
and from there that's sort of you know
that sort of made the whole issue of
whether I was
whether I was or wasn't that
the Insurrection a moot point because
basically it confirmed it in the minds
of everybody and so that was when
you know essentially that that became a
viral uh
article in itself is like oh he gets
dropped and very quickly that it sort of
it sort of gave the green light to
every every troll in their mother to
basically come out after me and it
basically put me on the receiving end of
death threats and the likes of which
I've you know I've never experienced
before and and hatred that that was just
that was Unleashed
um of course I you know it was
it was at least on on members of my
family it was at least on my on those
closest to me everyone that was in my
circle ran for the Hills
I mean I mean I mean I've made new
friends I've
and I have a wife and child now and
people know me now uh
she stuck by me but
but uh but but very few people
uh stuck by me and it's not just over
it's not just on uh
on uh political lines
like you know I haven't really spoken
that much to
my buddy who I went to uh
to the rally with so
I mean he they all got scared they all I
mean they didn't want to get their my
stink on them I mean that's it's it's
it's assassination by association so
and that's what happens everybody's
basically like you know running for
cover well the guys you went to the
rally with
distance you set themselves from you
right now they're scared that they're
they're gonna they might have a I mean
I'm I'm guessing that this is they were
scared they were scared they didn't want
to have people the FBI out their
doorstep you know what I'm saying they I
mean he was actually at the thing and
arguably
arguably he he's one of the reasons that
like you know that they assumed that I
was there
because he did a selfie or something
like that and posted that and then they
saw that then they knew because of the
photographs in the hotel room they put
two and two together they assumed there
was no eyewitness okay saying that I was
there that's the thing okay so so they
just
the reporting on it basically took admit
everybody was basically making up these
things because they needed to make them
up and this is this is the feeling that
I've been getting from
chiefly from the left the left-wing
media for quite some time now I think
they they still do it
egregiously
I mean uh you know I'm sure
the right wing media I'm sure Fox News
does it too but
less so I think
but uh but there's there seems to be a
they don't care about the facts anymore
and they're expecting me to like
actually believe that they can actually
that they they could they can actually
be accountable for things I mean I mean
it would make a big it's a it's an
important distinction if I wasn't there
if I wasn't there and I wasn't attending
and I wasn't part of the most
you know the most The Darkest Day in the
history of the United States
which is what Biden says that it was
okay like since the Civil War don't
worry about it he's forgotten about it
already no about beloved everybody's but
everybody forgets it I mean he's he's
not forgotten about it is he came out
like uh the Darth Maul uh uh in in the
latest thing you know saying that that
Maga extremists
you know not not he's not even he's this
he's he's
he's unifying he's saying he's like he's
like Republicans are good Republicans
are okay now but like it's the mega
extremists
and I mean that's when you say that
that's what is that what is that uh what
do you what are you setting up what do
you what do you got up down up your
sleeve what are you saying
and uh and I've seen the smear campaign
that they've done over the past
I mean they haven't they haven't uh
repatriated anybody they haven't gotten
on any they've been unified the country
he's supposed to you know
he's supposed to unify the country but
he's only
only stigmatized and ostracized as far
as I can tell
um you would have thought that by now my
friends would have
came to their senses and uh
realized that you know the coast is
clear and maybe like you know they
flinched or something like that and it
became come back and say like sorry
we weren't there for you blah blah blah
but we know that that's not the way the
world works and and
there's probably a lot of Shame there
which I'm
or maybe there's just still a lot of
Anger from them a lot of them probably
had like
have to convince themselves that I did
something to
to provoke their
their
distance and their you know to get to
make them wary of
ever talking to me again so
I know for a fact that there's certain
certain people that I know that are just
yeah they kind of like some of them did
you know they had basically do some sort
of social thing they had to go onto
Twitter
and
by virtue of the fact that they were
associated with me and known to be
associated with me
they had to in order to like you know
save face or like they even get back in
the good graces of their their circles
they had to make some sort of
gesture like you know like it's so sad
to see Ariel go down this path I knew
the drugs were you know
where I told I I knew that he was going
down the terrible path and the drugs
have just gotten to him he needs to go
back home and take it you know and and
reassess his life and I hope this this
is a wake-up call for him
every why is it that um now the very
famous Hollywood actress and star
Kirstie Alley passed away a couple of
days ago now and she might hear about
that yeah yeah and she made a point
because she was a trump supporter and
she said the words it's fine in
Hollywood to smoke meth and sleep with
hookers but it's not fine to vote for
Trump why is that
uh that's uh that's the question I mean
I I wouldn't venture to to know the
answer of that
um it is the facts
um
uh
yeah why can't uh
why is Hollywood
um
you know uh when half the country like
you know voted for him
arguably more
because I guess the the question that
I'm trying to get to Ariel is artists
they're meant to be the free thinkers
the whole purpose of art or music in
many ways is to see the world through
the eyes of someone who looks at The
World Slightly differently who looks at
The World Slightly Askew you'd think
that you'd think that that was the case
but yet apparently this is not the case
anymore
and that's and there was never nobody
told me
I mean I might have never done it if
like I basically realized what was what
was what I was
risking I didn't realize how thoroughly
everybody I underestimated how just how
enslaved my uh my uh my my friends my my
peers my my entire city
how everybody would just basically
because what I think it is is that like
people just really care so much about
what other people think about them now
more than they ever did before in the
past I think they've cared about it but
there wasn't a big enough uh
I don't know I just think that like you
know something about social media kind
of probably makes people hyper aware of
what they appear like to other people
and that makes the some sort of anxiety
sets in and people literally will they'd
rather
you know jump in the ocean then actually
risk
losing uh their friend group
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean up executed for
not being real men which is correct well
for those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped other global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this off is legit and
will have you smelling like royalty the
good kind not prince Andrew get 20 off
and free shipping with the code trigger
20 at manscape.com that's 20 off and
free shipping with the code trigger 20
at manscape.com it's time to throw out
all your old hygiene habits and upgrade
your life
you say that and they're very like
strong words you said that they people
were enslaved your friendship group were
enslaved now I imagine that a lot of
your friendship group are artists what
effect does that then have on Art and
the art that you are creating in the art
that Hollywood creates if people are
enslaved well I think that's you know
these are the questions that need to be
asked and and I'm not I don't know I
don't know what it means I don't I just
know that it can't be good
I don't think I would ever uh encourage
somebody to go down the path of
self-expression if uh with in this
climate I mean I you know and I never
thought I'd ever say that
it's I never thought that like the first
amendment was was that up for debate
I thought it was one of those uh
just uh those pillars of
of of American democracy I just never
thought it would even
ever be up for question but now you hear
people you know saying that like you
know free speech is like you know
it's uh it's a right-wing conspiracy
it's a right right right wing
Point yeah and as if as if it has
anything to do with partisan politics
it's just like it's the first it's the
first amendment every other Amendment
afterwards
it's not like it's like down on the list
not like 26 or like you know like like
abortion right it's like everything
flows from the First Amendment the only
way that you have a constitution is by
stating that thing and so if you throw
that out I don't understand like what
you think you have after that I mean do
we have a repo do we have a republic at
all
no it's it's to me it's it's in my
opinion
it's a no-brainer I mean I'm not even
that political but like it's just I can
see I understand like what would happen
if like we started to ban things the
same way that uh
you know other countries seem to ban
things and it seems like it's you know a
freedom of speech seems to be a good a
good way to sort of uh
as sort of a good Baseline for basically
what you want to call it
allowing people to say things
and I've said lots of things
you know and I I didn't if I had I known
I never expected that those things would
come back to haunt me especially because
I but I was I was definitely like you
know I was taking the temperature always
of of the free speech that I had and the
the platform that I had and I was uh I
felt like I could be
pretty
I didn't think that guy had to basically
uh be honest as much as uh
I've allowed myself to be uh
uh
uh uh unvarnished you know like I
basically was just able to
uh free associate in many interviews and
I got this
this you know you can look up by
interviews you can see what I've said
I never thought that those things were
going to be used against me later on I
mean I I was exercising my free speech
and uh you know I'm not worried about uh
people you know coming up to me and
saying well you said that you said that
you you do you believe that and it's
just like
maybe I do maybe I don't it doesn't
matter because there's free speech and I
can say it and nobody's going to deny me
that because there's free speech I mean
as long as I don't do anything but
surely Ariel the push back to that is
yeah but free speech does have certain
consequences if you say something people
will never to be thinking well that's
what you believe in therefore you're
that I said I've said that like I love
the Westboro Baptist Church
now now you know I got a lot of slack
for that at the time
I can see mate that's kind of a you know
what I mean but I mean people don't
don't really investigate it they think
I'm just being edgy and or just being
like a provocative and I am but like
there's more to it than that I mean they
are they are human beings
they have a reason for being that is is
sort of like not talked about
I'm I'm what they do is they sort of
they like to tell people that they're
that they're going to go to hell but
they're telling people that don't
believe in heaven or hell they're going
to go to hell and it gets these people
upset
they shouldn't be upset because they're
not going to go to hell they don't
believe in it
but they are management you know it's a
family of lawyers
they're just these people are they're
they're they're provoking people to
basically
physically assault
and basically
seizing on that weakness I think that's
kind of like what I liked about it was
that like it was basically calling
people's Bluff and basically like a
anybody that basically would attack them
for saying you're gonna go to hell it's
like who cares what they're saying if
you can if you you know
what is the big deal look I'm rubbing
your glue whatever you say bounce off me
and sticks on you
it's just words
and you need the consequences are that
people get physical they they get driven
to do things and then they think that
like you know and then then these
lawyers probably like you know their
whole reason for being is basically like
like
just
just
seizing on that and I I don't think it's
a very Noble purpose but I think that it
actually has a very American thing uh
behind it but surely we're onwards a
reflection of your character Ariel like
for instance you you know you say that
you were being provocative and you are a
provocative person and I would say that
you're not you're a contrarian if I mean
a world-class contrarians yeah exactly
so there goes the American modesty yeah
but so doesn't that then reflect your
character the words that you use reflect
your character like what you said about
Westborough Baptist Church doesn't that
reflect slightly who you are and the way
you think it reflects on who I was uh or
what I was saying at the time
um you could extrapolate all sorts of
things but the consequences of that
should not be
you know I could say
that I did something uh totally illegal
the fact that I didn't do that thing
should make it clear of consequences I
think I mean I mean like I can say what
I'm saying is that people
what's true and what isn't and what's
honest and what isn't is a very very
it's it's a it's a murky area it's murky
area I mean we what I'm saying is that
like things are not always what they
seem
don't judge a book by its cover look
read between the lines and maybe I'm
wrong about lots of these things but
like all right well speaking of being
wrong since Francis refuses to this is a
black question I'm gonna ask it which is
why did you support Donald Trump you say
you're not political you say it's not
something interesting I felt I felt like
Donald Trump I related to his you know
all these people hating on him
I I'd
experienced that kind of
the kind of uh that kind of media
attention that that he got I mean he got
it so much worse than I did ever yeah
but but I had but I know I've been
involved in media long enough to know
exactly what they do and
I'm no stranger to the the sort of uh
you know the sort of a Lynch Mob out
there of like you know
liable to sort of these paid campaigns
that they try to do to smear somebody
need to take some of these words and
basically like you know recast them as
the enemy to basically make them
stumble and make them like you know a a
Flinch or or screw up or say something
even more Dumber you know and then and
just make themselves uh uh
to sort of like you know uh prove them
right and essentially you know it's it's
like a the media really likes to take
take down its uh its uh subjects it
likes to bring them up and then it
basically loves to take them down
and so and it didn't really work for me
for them I mean with regards to me I
mean first of all I was never
anywhere that what's the takedown I mean
I never really got anywhere nobody knows
about me
but but but but but the point is that
like I
I had experienced uh uh an intense smear
campaign on me that was completely holy
out of the whole cloth you know without
any reason
uh uh
uh I'd experienced several of those
um you know and they you know the people
saying that I was a misogynist people
say people yeah referring to actually
the interview with the bat that I said
uh the Baptist Church that I like the
Baptist Church that was a big deal it's
like I mean I've said something like I
didn't uh
I didn't believe in uh
I didn't believe in gay marriage or
something like that I think it was like
I didn't believe in marriage actually
so they just thought far less
controversial position yeah no exactly
strangely enough yeah but but but but
but but but
uh so so so these are just you know
these are just things that I said yeah
and that's the point is that like you
know people take these things way too
seriously to take what people say people
what's happening with Kanye right now I
mean I and this is a Hot Topic is what
he's saying
is is he an anti-Semitism is that that
what we're talking about it's like well
in my opinion
as somebody that's been
attacked
stigmatized by the media and by and the
guy's got
he had a family
he has he's been he's been called Crazy
by everybody by the media
he's he has to basically redeem himself
in the media's eyes
I mean that's just gonna you you're just
basically like you know you're just like
poking at
this person is not gonna
he just does not know
I I feel sorry for him I mean I I feel
for the guy because I know what it feels
like to basically have the world against
you okay but yeah
hold on a second hold on a second I'm
not excusing him I know I know you're
not excusing him and I feel sorry for
him as well because I don't think he's
very well mentally okay then I think
there are people using him however if
you go no one is poking him he chose to
go on all those podcasts he chose to say
I like Hitler and Alex Jones Is there
going uh I know you're just trying to be
shocking and and Kanye says I'm not
trying to be shocking I like Hitler I I
think in that situation you can't expect
people not to push back against us well
let's let's sue him for a trillion
dollars
that's what they did to Alex Jones I
mean yeah but Alex Jones defamed people
who whose children were victims over
didn't he yes that's what the court
found that's why he's being sued that's
why he's gonna have to pay 1.4 billion
dollars but that is a different separate
issue
um the Kanye thing is see this is one of
the problems with I think in with our
societies we've got to a point where
we're prepared to like people just
because they're saying [ __ ] you to the
mainstream right so this is why I was
curious why you like Donald Trump
because or no sorry you didn't even say
you like Donald Trump why you voted for
him and the answer you gave is well I
know what it's like to be smeared we all
do in this room we've all been smart
right I I think I think I I definitely
well if I'm if I'm gonna be honest I
mean what I've what I felt was that I
really
when we voted out
when we didn't when we voted him in in
2016 I think that that was the that was
a memorandum that was that was basically
like a a
that was that was us saying that we
didn't want
that regime that had been there uh prior
okay we all thought that we were all
told that
the um
we were told that he had no chance of
winning right by the media the media in
and I'm talking about the right wing and
the left wing was in unison and hated
one person okay before he ever stepped
foot in the white house and they accused
him of all these things
and they really just did it was the
first time that it it occurred to me
that the media was actually in the
pocket of a specific party
and more than that that specific party
was also the other party
it was just basically controlled
opposition
they were against him because he was an
outsider and and they thought that they
could just basically tell you
what you were gonna do
and the the difference between like I
think uh
between now and then is that
I think that they were I think there was
a level of wishful thinking on the part
of the media and liberals at the time
they were basically
saying
this is what's going to happen this is
what's going to happen because they
hoped that that's what was going to
happen now
when they said he's not going to
actually have another four years they
were saying there's no way he's going to
have another four years we're not going
to happen
and that's the impression and they were
they meant it okay what I'm saying is
like they made sure that there wasn't
any chance of that happening whereas
back then they
they were just saying it hoping and I
think that that's that's what that's the
extremism that you've sensed nowadays
and the the sort of the heightened
heightened tension everywhere is is a is
because of that and that's the thing
that that to me is is what's really the
difference in all this and um
Okay cool so
um all of that makes sense to me I
personally I'm not a fan of Donald Trump
neither Francis no that's fine yeah but
I agree with you entirely and I've
written a lot and talked a lot about the
fact that uh he was not treated fairly
the suppression of the hunter Biden
laptop was an outrage by the big tech
companies uh a lot of lies were told
about Donald Trump uh I am not uh at all
comfortable with the fact that both
sides
um in 2016 the Democrats they denied the
results of the election Hillary Clinton
is on record saying he's an illegitimate
presence so I agree with you that he was
not treated fairly and that's because of
the visceral hatred that a lot of people
uh felt towards him right and so your
your reaction to go well these people
are all demonizing this guy I'm gonna
support him I understand but I also
think that it's quite a sad State of
Affairs that that is how how we make our
decisions about who to vote for would
you agree with that well you know uh
from what I I know it sounds uh it
sounds uh
it sounds kind of like you know just as
bad but but I'm intending to feel like
the people that get canceled
these days have a have a funny way of
being
really decent people
and and they're being canceled
almost because they're decent uh do you
think Donald Trump's a decent person
I'm inclined to think maybe he actually
is
I wouldn't have thought so before but
now that I start to see when I see
Winston and stuff like Winston
people like Winston getting canceled
me
um other people that I know
um
it the only thing that they seem to have
in common is that they're sensible
and I think that like you know there
seems to it seems the canceling you know
like I mean there's always been you know
I think the right wing
the difference is that the right wing
like doesn't really have the power to
cancel anybody they might want 20 years
ago but even then even then even then I
mean they canceled Milo Milo yonopolis
was canceled by the right and Marta
would say that in his own world well
that's different what I'm saying is that
they don't have they can't cancel
anybody on the left okay
they they
I expect to see a bunch of people at a
Marilyn Manson concert always you know
in the parking like basically like you
know uh protesting it and trying to like
you know stop it from happening it never
happens okay because they don't have the
power to do that and I I but I applaud
their their their efforts they might
want to cancel I mean I think everybody
wants to be able to cancel they don't
have the power to
the left has the power and they use it
so they basically in my opinion they
have a responsibility to use it wisely
or they to use it sparingly because it's
an abuse of power
the right doesn't have the power to
prevent a personality like Donald Trump
to come in and on the Republican ticket
because basically they are they've been
kept Weak by the Democratic party as a
matter of strategy
they're basically the Republicans have
been toothless since since the Clinton
era
and that's been their strategies they're
just sort of like you know
have the suit come out every election
season uh while while uh then you have
you know uh
Clinton come on in our studio Hall and
[ __ ] play a saxophone and basically
throw them out of the water and I mean
they're just there to make
Democrats look good
during election season and that's that's
how it feels I mean they're just they
don't have any Charisma they don't have
any appeal they don't really have any
uh they don't have any message that kind
of stuff
so
what I what I appreciate I mean and
Donald Trump was a Democrat prior to
prior to this so
what I appreciate is that he wasn't as
bad as they said he was as they feared
he was and as they accused him of being
before he even stepped foot in in the
White House they never gave him a chance
he didn't destroy the country although
they want to say that he did
but he didn't he didn't have any designs
he didn't kill people overseas he didn't
put put this in war
he's not that bad as far I was I kind of
liked I kind of liked not having not
being at War for four years it was nice
while it lasted every it seems to me
about listening to you that you feel
that we're being manipulated yes
I do why is that and who who are the
people and who are the ones doing the
manipulation I think uh you know I'm not
gonna name names but
uh it's been out in the open since
as far as I can remember I mean like I
mean
I
mean
is it any is it any
you'd understand too like I mean I I I
toured the world
I I've been touring the world regularly
uh like 130 days a year uh on average I
would say for 20 years or very 18 years
I would say
up until uh yeah a little bit before the
pandemic so I'm in towards since then
um but uh
so I've spent a lot of time abroad and
I've been you know I've I've been to
places that I never
would have thought I would go I've been
to elanbatar
I I don't think anybody in my city has
ever gone to a woman guitar I don't
think anybody in rock and roll has ever
gone to a little on guitar I've been to
I've been to Moscow I've been to Saint
Petersburg I love these places
I have audiences everywhere
I feel
I feel like I need to call each one of
them all my fans in these places and
apologize
for things that like my government does
and I feel
it's unfair
and they shouldn't have to suffer
and I feel a deep empathy
for
for I mean I just feel like you know
we can be wrong sometimes you know we
gotta just admit it if we don't if if we
just I'm
I was I'm pro-american but like I I
can't do it anymore man so who come back
to the manipulating point because I
think this is I hear a lot of people
saying stuff like this but they never
really explain what they mean and you
just didn't either okay okay well I'll
say what else I'll be more blunt about
it
when I was yeah when I was in my or uh
you know in the late 90s I remember uh
uh a guy named Bill Gates
coming out and saying
you know
some of the big the biggest uh worry for
for Humanity is you know overpopulation
and basically we need to reduce the
population by such and such and this was
just something that he just said
multiple times it was I remember it like
it was yesterday
then you have the pandemic happen
and he's behind the vaccine
and he's out there basically pitching
the thing and saying that this is going
to save lives
and I'm thinking to myself
what if it saves lives
what if it works out what if these
things actually save lives what will
happen to your prediction about what
will happen to your
your vision of the future where you say
that we have to like actually like
reduce the population by it by a
significant amount
I mean this is to save Humanity
to me it seems like
the whole the whole program
uh uh has been sort of pushed on us the
whole climate uh stuff and this is where
I get you know I'm probably your garden
variety
tin foil hat q q non kind of style
conspiracy theorists but uh this is out
of their mouths
why would I ever like listen to that guy
for health when I know what he thinks is
like you know the prescription for our
future when I know that basically he's
already uh said that like you know
climate is the most important thing and
yet none of our uh
none of our uh
you know deals or across the the world
in the past 20 years have reduced
any uh carbon emissions
they've only it's only been exacerbated
and uh this is with I just don't
understand
um
I feel I've starting to feel like it's
and I feel like they're panicking
because they start to realize like how
how intensely they pushed these things
on us
they they're they were they were being
alarmists they're trying to basically
push these things into the foreground
but like we have to we have time out
guys we gotta focus on saving the trees
saving that you know getting rid of
these Greenhouse men because you
basically reduce the population all
these things that basically
to me seemed
like they were a little bit
I mean it's just they set it up I mean
they basically like who who's do they so
we've got Bill Gates on on the board Al
Gore uh the same person that basically
gave us the uh who pitched the internet
to and gave gave us you know gave
everybody you know said there was going
to be this breakthrough and and
communication and and gave us gave
everybody a sample taste uh back in the
day the whole world and got everybody
hooked on it
and and and it seems to me like it's
almost the the control that they have
been able to affect
in the results globally
it took about 20 years but I think they
really that they've honed it and they've
it's meant you know they've they've been
saying this is where it's going this is
where it's going you don't have a choice
where AI is gonna it's a boogie man
that's like in the distance is good it's
there it's like it's like well why don't
we turn it off then I mean why don't we
turn around I mean like what I'm saying
like why why do we think that's a good
thing is it AI it dictates all of our
choices why why is that a good thing how
is that going to work out for our
country as in Americans how does
globalism I mean is that not globalism
is the internet is global
uh how does how does that not uh how
does not how is that is that a free
speech platform yeah it's pretty free
speech it's unpleasable
but how is that not going to destroy
governments worldwide has not gonna that
not going to interfere I was not not how
is that not meant to interfere and
destroy
I know I hear what you're saying but
what about I mean it seems like this is
the Eternal story of humanities we
invent technologies that break the
existing order but we but we seem to
have uh there seems to be a
predestination that's sort of why do you
say that because what's the
predestination where wherever they say
it's going like it's inevitable so where
are we going then what they where they
say that we're going which is what
we're going to have a a
very you know what they say I guess I
guess it's a we're gonna go what is the
great reset thing it's like you're gonna
be you're gonna you're not gonna own
anything and you're gonna be happy
uh you're not you know they're the
digital currency they're getting rid of
money
it's all it's all been decided in
advance and I think that like uh it
seems I mean if that's not the case then
I'm wrong you know but it seems to be
that like everything's been accelerated
ever since
Donald Trump got in power
do you think Trump was an antidote to
that then do you think he was one of the
people fighting back again I think he
was a mistake that's just my personal
opinion if I'm wrong then he was a plant
and either way it's still the fault of
the other side
so basically there's still there's still
the bad guys in the way the other the
the the the issue that I have with this
way of thinking Ariel is I just don't
think human beings any human being is
that competent or that intelligent to be
able to create this kind of this kind of
like conspiracy well yeah because I
conspiracy though it's it's it's I don't
think that like the people on the left
are aware that they are basically
colluding in these ways out of some sort
of like knowledge I I don't think it's
like an intellectual thing I think it's
it's a
it's a it's they they are willing and I
think the the power of the mind it
manifests things and I think that like
it's it's a it's a strange thing where
you have basically everybody acting a
specific way and then all of a sudden
everybody's basically acting in unison
against some other party and it's so
easy to basically like turn
everybody into
you know a a
is sort of a good faith policeman you
know for their for their social order or
whatever but this is this is the point
I'm trying to make too is this is the
entire story of humanity it happened in
the Soviet Union where I grew up it
happened in Nazi Germany it happened
no no of course we don't it happened
during the Salem Witch Trials it
happened in almost every civilization at
one point or another because human
beings are tribal human beings are
largely conformist human beings are
influenced by a small minority of people
to believe things that aren't true and
this is this is what happens but once
you start to say well they have
orchestrated this this is where I
struggled to see it because you're
making claims that to me because of what
Francis says just seemed quite
unrealistic like to get a bunch of
people doesn't you don't have to call it
a conspiracy like we run trigonometry
which is like a small YouTube channel
with like 10 Stars let me just finish
this point right we can't get a [ __ ]
episode to go out on time now we are
probably not as smart as big get Bill
Gates I'm just saying the human you are
okay well that's very kind of you to say
or maybe unkind of you to say but my
point is it's hard to get anything to to
to be the way that somebody intended and
human beings are very complicated and I
I agree with you that when you look out
into the world and you see like
sometimes I look at the way people on
the right and the left talk about
certain issues and it seems like that
you know that NPC thing that people talk
of a non-player character where people
are not thinking they are regurgitating
a line that they heard somewhere else
like I I just did a bunch of Articles
and and um tweet threads about the
hunter Biden lab story going like no no
this is a big story Elon Musk putting
out what happened is a big story and and
all the negative replies they're
literally copy paste like so they say
the same stuff and whatever but do I
believe that they got handed out that
talking point at you know some kind of
meeting with Bill Gates probably not do
you know what I mean I just believe
they're real the real people most of
them are yeah yeah right okay so then so
then don't you feel like it's at that
this is the most it's it's it's funny
that at this time you know not any other
time prior that at this time it's
necessary to have these discussions the
way that you're having them
intelligently and to and to it's really
important but it happens to be the same
time when the powers that be seem to
have uh
a new a new uh ability to basically like
shut down people at will whenever they
want to well this is well this isn't
again is that a coincidence no no but
hold on but again this this is uh you
you're not taking history into account
now but 500 years I am I am okay but 500
years ago the government had way more
power to shut you down than it does now
they'd rip out your tongue physically I
get it I get it I get it I get it again
but you're but you're saying that like
either we're not going anywhere are we
are we getting somewhere like you know
like are we going are we we just are we
just cyclically just doomed to basically
become tribal people because okay yeah
okay okay okay
then what is the point of having the
first amendment in the United States for
instance okay yeah like why has this not
happened yet okay what I'm saying is
we've gotten rid as an American and I
don't know you know I know you guys have
been
England is probably is probably a dream
in comparison to
to Russia
that said
I quite liked America and America has
been the
the sort of like you know for better for
worse has been sort of like the the the
police the the the the sort of the big
dad on the scene the big guy on the
scene that basically the whole world is
sort of like you know they've been sort
of
captive to and then you know basically
uh you know they basically molding
itself to the values that we have yeah
we consume your culture yeah and you
guys and you guys are you know doomed to
sort of repeat it so I agree so well
well you know there seems to be some
sort of uh consensus at this moment that
like that's on its way out right there
seems to be like an understanding and an
accepting of the idea that like the
United States they had their time and
now it's time for them to take a sleep
and for some other some they can go into
slip into number two there's got to be
another number one and this is just a
cyclical it's what happens to all
Empires
and that's and and I think that that's
what is being willed into existence and
Trump definitely opposed that yeah
that's what that's what I I'm
I yes that makes all perfect sense to me
that's why but when you start talking
about they when you start saying that
this is all planned that's where no I
don't say it's all planned I'm saying
that it's willed what I'm saying is that
like it's it's it's it's kind of like
the Stay Puft Marshmallow Man in
Ghostbusters you know I'm saying like
like try try to think of something
benign or don't think of anything clear
your mind and then all of a sudden the
state this giant
Stay Puft Marshmallow Man comes out
because the guy thought like the most
harmless thing he could possibly think
of and it's basically trampling over the
whole entire town is your argument just
to clarify that they that there is that
there are Elites as like our gold Bill
Gates these type of people well and we
can all agree that they're Elites and
they are fit and they are willing that
we move towards this different way of
living with AI where we're monitored
where we're we're in silence we've been
saying things they've been saying things
as if like they're basically inevitable
inevitable things that are going to
happen that you know when you think
about like you know when you think about
these robo dogs that they're gonna like
unleash you know like to do certain
things when you think about digital
currency when you think about like all
these things that basically like even
just two years ago you really didn't
even actually hear about until two years
ago and they're just basically
accelerating all this and the people
that like kind of like bark at like you
know the prospect of these things
happening they're called you know like
kind of like conspiracy theorists at
first but then it's basically every it
starts to like basically gain traction
because people just basically get
exposed to it more and they basically
knowing the psychology of people this
system basically knows exactly how to
basically like just like expose people
to these things and make them extremely
suggestible so basically everybody's you
know nobody's really in control anymore
basically there's there's some other
apparatus that is stripping us of our
own autonomy
and in in in and dragging us along
whether we like it or not
along this path and I mean I don't know
what what is responsible for that but I
don't like it and I like I like autonomy
I like being able to decide my what kind
of music I make I like to be able to
like
say what I say you know I like that that
that that that nothing that I've ever
said has been that controversial it's
just been just kind of like
playing playing around just [ __ ] just
saying things it's the consequences have
always been my butt I mean I basically
it's like no I've never heard anybody
nothing I've said is it ever made
somebody do something crazy
it's always just been like oh
Ariel really stepped in it this time no
no this this uh love of freedom and
autonomy and wanting to push back I mean
as Francis was saying Earl it's a job of
artists it's the job of people like you
I I'm on board with all of that I think
that that's brilliant I I'm just
wondering why the and the reason I'm
discussing this with you is I think
you're very articulate about it and I
hear This Thread of thinking a lot
online from people those are them and
they are trying and they're willing and
they're doing it and us what I'm saying
what I'm saying is when I say them I
mean I'm just well no you said Bill
Gates and Al Gore but no it's us it's us
it's you and it's you as well
I mean the point is that like I I'm not
I'm not I don't have the power to stop
it from where it's going right yeah what
I'm saying is
it's all of us we all but but the world
is not has not been decided
is not is not a a foregone conclusion
that we shouldn't actually take we
should we take it for granted we think
that basically these these these
authorities know what they're what's
gonna happen and know what they're
talking about and they talk about things
and we believe that they understand
things more than we do and I totally
understand
made some politicians believe me they
don't know but but they act like they
sound like they do and they talk like
they do and it's very scary because they
probably do
in some way and maybe we're not
appreciating it because we're basically
like writing them off and calling them
you know kind of dumb well it's like but
like we're the ones that are the same
I'll tell you it's like it's it's it's
it's to me it's it's it's it's painfully
obvious that like what is happening to
our culture and everything is artificial
it's not like this to you it's because
it's not organic it's not it's been it's
been it's been it's very heavy-handed
what's been happening has been a steady
campaign of hatred against
specific one person like our president
by the media
it sounds to me you know what it feels
like to me it feels like somebody that's
basically
trying to cover up something
that's what it is it sounds like
somebody that's trying that feels guilty
about what they did or not feel guilty
but basically is somebody protests a
little bit too much
it feels to me like they're trying to
desperately cover up something that they
did that they're afraid is going to
experience mail for just a counter
counter explanation that I think is just
easier to sell right which is this
Donald Trump broke every moral code of
the progressive left how he's obnoxious
he says things you're not supposed to
say he's politically incorrect he is
Brash he is the embodiment of a form of
masculinity which you're not supposed to
have in the modern world right
masculinity bad femininity good right
um he he challenged the the point that
you made which is very good point he
challenged the idea of manage decline
this is something that Steve Bannon and
Donald Trump both talked about a lot
challenged the idea that America is
supposed to you know take a nap or take
a rest or whatever it was you said to go
down
um and he represented both politically
in terms of policy but also you know
dealing dealing with the the Border
you're not supposed to talk about it
right just like in this country you're
not supposed to talk about but why
aren't you supposed to talk about that
because because to those people on the
left these are subjects that are just
out of the Realms of their globalists
okay yeah it's fine I totally agree so
they're not for countries I agree okay
so so that's then we should what we're
asking this why it's a presidential
election for a country I'm not I'm not
I'm not voting for the ruler of the
world I'm voting for the ruler of for
the president for four years okay I get
it so so I'm just trying to explain why
I think they would want to destroy
someone like that of course of course
because they've been brainwashed because
they don't believe in countries because
they don't believe in money because they
don't believe in borders because they
want to destroy the they don't believe
in a country those people should not be
eligible to be president okay I'm sorry
and it's just the people they're against
parents they're against men being uh you
know a a the nuclear family okay they're
they're that's offensive to them that's
since when is that the case okay okay
there's nothing okay and don't he's not
offensive if you listen to what he said
you'd realize that he's a lot more
practical sensible I listen to a lot of
what John John said I I always he's been
I've always been very fair but I I'm
trying to explain to you why people on
that side I understand why because
they've been because their minds are
have been corrupted and they don't
really have that much agency they don't
they're and also they're younger okay
typically Democrats are younger people
because they don't have much to to the
they don't own very much they got
nothing to their name so there's not
they want they don't mind like living uh
uh you know you know eating from sardine
cans and living with 10 people you know
they need each other obviously there's
they they need to get their life
together but like when you own stuff
when you're like basically when it comes
down to it is I mean like what what are
conservatives do you think they're just
like you know like like a a rednecks
with with a with a with a with a with a
chip on their shoulder about uh
different races now do they just
basically people that basically
conservatives in general
are people that basically like have
grown to uh to to to have a family and
basically they have a a house they own a
house
and taxes really make a big difference
taxes make a really big difference at
that point when when when you own a
house when you have a family to feed
it's not like like when you lived on
your own and you were making a killing
working at some agency or whatever and
you just didn't have any overhead okay
it makes a huge difference the taxes is
like such a such an easy kind of like
you can understand why people that have
like a little bit more money need that
need the taxes start to really really
impact their ability to live
when they have more expenses and when
you just when you just ignore that fact
when you when you have basically one
party that's basically exploiting the
the sort of
the lack of
the lack of resolve the lack I mean
basically it feels just very
exploitative I mean I mean because
because it to me the elites are are
Democrats largely by by and large at the
moment yeah at the moment so so it says
it's ironic to me
hey Francis if you were a member of the
public would you like the opportunity to
ask incredible guests like Bill Burr
Jordan Peterson Sam Harris Adam Carolla
Brett Weinstein John Barnes Douglas
Murray Nigel farage and Lionel Shriver
your own questions you bet I would and
what do you think the best way to do
that would be uh probably stalking mate
you'd have to Corner them in the
supermarket probably brand new like the
sort of frozen food of and then just
bought questions at them before they can
escape uh not the American ones as they
have guns and you have to be extra
careful with the females as that's how I
got in trouble last time
do you really imagine you're gonna get
Douglas Murray near the frozen food
aisle if you want to ask our incredible
guest questions and have access to
phenomenal behind the scenes content
then you have to be on our locals that's
right for only seven dollars a month you
get incredible extra content behind the
scenes footage giveaways and also the
chance to be part of an incredible
Community where you can meet and hang
out with like-minded people you get
access to our American Vlogs as we
travel across the country interviewing
Our Heroes an extra 20 minutes of our
viral Sam Harris episode as he discusses
his approach to covert we're also going
to start doing giveaways of exclusive
trigonometry merchandise like this a
poster from our Edinburgh show signed by
both of us and also a House of Lords
Teddy which you can only get in the
House of Lords signed by the one and
only baroness Fox
locals also gives you access to an
incredible online community you can
share memes talk about the latest
episode or even make a new friend or
just one exactly more than both of us
have really people are now doing meetups
in their City because they love locals
in fact some people enjoy it so much
they prefer it over the show they prefer
locals to trigonometry
if I have to get them executed I'm the
one that goes to jail right go to
trigonometry.locals.com only seven
dollars a month for all that incredible
content
trigonometry.locals.com See you there
guys
I'm listening to you talk and your
passion Ariel and look I get it do you
think part of it is the fact that you
live in Los Angeles where you are at the
very almost very epicenter of this
ideology you're 45 years old you were
there before and you suddenly saw it
creep in and not only did you see it
creep in in one of the you know in one
of the wokest places in the world you're
working in one of the wokest industries
and you see more and more of your
friends adopt this ideology well it
never was that it wasn't that it wasn't
work I mean there's only one oh sorry
like the progressivism or the idea sorry
the ideology that that you're talking
about I'm do you see and you're more
sensitive to it because you're quite
literally at the center of it plus
you've also described yourself as a
contrarian do you see what I mean I'm
the most liberal person that you've ever
met I was born and raised in LA and my
values are
I've met one I don't think I've met one
conservative in my entire life okay like
I mean the people that I am like is like
the people that I was raised around are
my friends
we have the same values I mean I mean
I'm more liberal than anybody
that has canceled me okay I mean I know
that for a fact I mean I'm a rock star
I I I I I I was raised in La I don't
know anything else whether I wanted to
actually if I wanted to be uh
if I wanted to be a you know a Puritan
or if I wanted to be anything that
that's associated with the with the let
with the right uh uh I probably I
wouldn't know where to start but I've
just I'm I'm as West Coast liberal La as
you can imagine and it is my home it was
where I was born and raised I don't know
I didn't come there from another
small town to make it or anything like
that I am a country bumpkin that's all I
know yeah and I've never lived anywhere
else my family's there so I never left I
am I embody
the liberal ideal
which up until
five minutes ago was
the liberal ideal now it is a woke
police state
that I'm basically shunned from and that
they that that that that does not embody
any of the um any of the virtues that
that that it that it that only uh five
minutes ago it was touting well it was
completely illiberal this is why we
opposed it because it's illiberal so so
when you say so when you say is that
because I'm in La I don't think it
matters that I'm in LA
because the fact that I'm from La is is
what what did me in
and it's not coming from France's point
is you it you saw the biggest
transformation right you were living in
the place where the culture changed so
quickly not just L.A it's so badly
Silicon Valley of course yeah so what
I'm saying in California California
witnessed the entire transformation I
think that's the the United States and
of course through big Tech which comes
from Silicon Valley those values leak
out onto the rest those values were like
sort of like whatever happened in in La
sort of like this there's a feeling that
it would happen everywhere else in the
world 10 years from now yes yes exactly
and so so
it feels it seems like it's on the
Forefront of things and so maybe there
is something about that to me that is a
little bit like kind of like a a a wants
to sort of like you know ring the bell
and be like hey wait wait wait wait look
this is where it's going guys maybe we
gotta turn back right now yeah sure
that's what that's yeah but I guess the
reason we're having this entire
discussion is basically this that I
think you think because this
transformation has been so dramatic and
so rapid and so unnatural and so counter
to your values you're going well this
must be somehow minute you said
manipulated or these people are involved
yeah I think it's artificial artificial
is the word right and I think an equally
credible and probably certainly to me
much more credible thing is we've had a
gigantic technological transformation
just like the invention of the printing
press or hold on that that allows for a
different type of communication which is
more suited to certain ideas than others
because this is the problem with social
media social media naturally rewards
certain types of ideas of others and
ideas that are rewards ideas that may
sound good but are impractical so for
example you go on Twitter and you say
there is no difference between men and
women on Twitter that works
it works on Twitter because it's not
real life you can say there's no
difference between men and women and
there'll be a [ __ ] ton of people who
agree with it because they like that
idea even though it's completely untrue
right so you have a technological
transformation that leads to the
propagation of certain ideas and that
that does not necessarily have to be the
product of a conspiratory do you think
that it's Market demands uh I I think
that as I say I think it is a
technological shift that changes the way
we consume information like you are a
different person on Twitter than you are
in real life so am I so is Francis so is
everybody else why is that because the
technology channels us into behaving in
particular ways it's like when you're
driving your car and someone cuts you up
because you're behind the windscreen
windscreen because there's that distance
you behave in ways that that you
wouldn't behave if you were Facebook
because it's a different medium
altogether it's it's not real life it's
it's right it's what I'm like on paper
you know or like when you read about it
it is completely it's a different thing
it's like a piece of but that's but
that's that's the listening to my music
is not me you're going to get a
different what I'm saying is these are
different realities but but what I'm
saying is
I think you get what I'm trying to say
is that might be true
but I think you're giving you think that
like
cancellation and these kinds of things
are driven by people's opinions and I'm
trying to tell you that
I don't believe that the people's
opinions are actually
the driving force of any of these
campaigns that basically yeah it's
tribes no they're actually they are
convincing themselves they're the
recipients
somebody gets canceled
for whatever for such and such reason
the people that basically
see the person get canceled
need to feel that they basically have an
opinion about the person being canceled
so they basically want to think that
they had a hand in canceling them when
in fact it's the other way around they
got canceled by some mechanism that is
beyond anybody's awareness or control
they don't understand what it is they're
not canceling they want to think of
themselves we want to think of ourselves
as sort of having a say in this thing
but there's some other mechanism that's
basically
getting us our thoughts and our opinions
and we are basically rationalizing it
because we think that we have a say in
this world but isn't that the opposite
of what happened to you you said
yourself you went to this rally people
conflated you go into a rally and being
part of the riot right and then your
label got a [ __ ] ton of pushback from
people and you got a [ __ ] ton of people
no what happened that's why they dropped
what happened was that there was a there
was articles that went out right without
any confirmation without any
corroboration without any reason without
any eyewitness because they were looking
for a scapegoat right well I mean if
they do that they usually get in the
lawsuits okay what I'm saying is that
like there's no ethical journalism they
what they do is they they basically are
are are are it's a there's a there's a
there's a board it's got hit hit they
can hit people whoever they want they
basically turn turn their attention to
this person we don't care about the uh
the ethics or the consequences of doing
this stuff
I don't get like you say there's a board
right that means there's a room in which
there's a board and then there's people
who are going let's pick on this person
now is that you you think that's what
happens well why didn't they correct it
no no just you think there's a room with
a board where people pick out a name and
go let's go after this guy I think
there's I think what there is is there's
a uh a wide scale
a wide scale uh sort of like we cannot
let him win
so we have to there's a I believe that
there was a an actual
it seems very weird to me that I was the
only person in Hollywood
that was outwardly pro-trump okay
every single magazine every single
institution unless they were like
already like
way right wing as far as they were
concerned you know
that that you know like that's these
people are like hopeless okay
own
uh uh a news uh whatever whatever the
other whatever the other Epoch you know
whatever whatever it is
those things are are already like right
wing and slanted as that but then
there's like everything else the New
York Times is like every single other I
mean every single magazine and every
single publication that could not ever
if you were if you could not be Pro it
would make an argument
but doesn't mean there's a room with a
board in there where people I believe
that there was an actually there was a
behind the scenes there was actually a
an agreement
behind the the
elitist the money and interests that
basically a round table that said we
will not allow any kind of positive
speaking of Donald Trump allowed in our
institutions in our magazines or in
anything that's there's like a like a
like a the moratorium basically like
that was just like basically like you
cannot do that and it was unspoken
what I'm saying is that there was nobody
that basically pushed back against no I
agree with you so why is that but that's
a group think that's group thing no it's
not no it is it happens in comedy weird
things happens all the time but hold on
hold on we it happens in comedy in
comedy there's a certain way of thinking
but no one sits down in a room with a
board and goes let's go after
trigonometry let's go after that I I get
it okay so listen so so in light of the
group thing
there's people thank God there's people
like me that are basically there to
throw a turtle to the punch bowl okay
sure as long as they're allowed to do
that sure I'm like I'm not allowed to do
that you are here no I'm in one other
country I'm a man with I'm telling you
it's not allowed in my country and you
you don't appreciate come and live in
L.A man I'm telling you you guys do you
got the whole world is Free Speech now
okay you guys you have to say you took
that from us we basically I you
everybody stands for that and they
appreciate that
you don't understand what happens when
the first world
when the United States loses that thing
and when they cancel people because of
it okay they would cancel people because
of what they believe in okay when they
cannot say when they cannot vote for a
president
I had if I had known that it was illegal
to vote for Donald Trump I probably
wouldn't have devoted for him but the
understanding was there no and I
basically I was that I was not allowed
to do that we are sympathetic to you
I know I know I know but what I'm saying
is this is just let's just focus on the
part of what you're saying that I'm very
hopefully respectfully and gently trying
to challenge which is the idea that and
the reason I'm having this discussion
with you I do I understand what you're
saying this is something that a lot of
people say and I think it's important
for people who like each other as we do
and who are interested in in each
other's point of view to have this part
of the conversation the fact that this
group think and the fact that there's
Conformity of views I find as abhorrent
as you do the fact that somebody cannot
vote for one of the two presidential
candidates without having their life
ruined is abhorrent to me and what
happened to you is atrocious right it
should never have happened that way the
way you were treated was awful that does
not mean that there's I'm using your
words now a round table it does not mean
that there's a room with a board on it
where they pick out who to go after it
just means in my opinion that there are
people who have a certain worldview and
I know many of these people right and
they're not nearly as competent or
capable as you'd like to think believe
me right and they just have a view that
there is the right way to see this and
they act accordingly so for example I
have a friend who works at one of the
major Publications in this country who I
know from before I started trigonometry
and him and I disagree very frequently
in 2016 when the hunter Biden laptop
story was published I was tweeting
saying this is really important this is
a big story and the cover-up is bigger
than the actual Story the fact that the
big Tech suppressor is the bigger and he
got really angry with me because he just
wanted his guy to win right and that is
how these people think that does not
mean there's a room with a board with a
round table there's some kind of cabal
there's some kind of thing I just don't
think that's the way but they've also
like admitted all that stuff though too
well they've admitted what oh you know I
mean there's an article about like you
know like uh uh how how there's that you
know the Secret Story on on how uh the
uh how the Democrats like you know like
banded up with uh with uh these uh these
different uh groups you know like in the
to to to to to collaborate to basically
yeah I read that out yeah yeah right so
so there's so but they didn't admit that
they sat down in a room of course these
people talk to each other
we had dinner last night that's all I'm
saying I'm all I'm saying is that like
there was an agreement that's all I'm
not saying that there's anything like
more nefarious than that you said there
was a board in a room and you said there
was a round table there was there was a
zoom call okay I mean what I'm saying I
I don't know what you're you're getting
at what I'm saying is there was
an obvious
there was like it wasn't just it goes
beyond
um it goes beyond uh
you know determination to win uh an
election okay I mean I can give them I
can give them props for like you know
going far and above and doing what was
necessary in order to win okay sorry
Francis you should go ahead yeah
no no no no no no no no no it's not it's
when I talk I've got a lot of empathy
for the way
for what for what you talk about Ariel
because I see I'll be honest with you
mate I see a lot of myself in you I used
to think that I was the most liberal guy
and you know I in the old-fashioned
sense you say what you feel yeah
no but you were you were but but we've
changed words we've changed words
do you think a lot of the strength that
you're feeling is because you lament an
America that no longer exists
uh uh yeah in a lament a career that no
longer exists as well
I mean I've always been about
I'm not Progressive at all I mean I'm
like you know
I'm like the future is worse than the
past I'm like the uh you know it are all
the best stuff already happened it's
hopeless basically and uh you gotta love
it while it's
you gotta love it while it's here the
moment is is the youngest you'll ever be
it's not going to be better you got to
appreciate what you have and hold on to
it and hold on to what you love the most
that's what I believe in I don't believe
in Progressive causes or anything like
that I think the whole world I mean we
we grow up and then we die there's the
the Human Arc of experience is a very
tragic thing and so I I believe that
hope might be a hyper vigilance in terms
of like you know things going in a
certain way is pretty pretty naive I
think that like there's there's probably
things are just gonna get worse
but we probably won't know the
difference we'll be happy uh slaves and
all that kind of stuff but I'm here to
basically
to to say
let's do the impossible and turn back
that's what I think is necessary I don't
think we should make a virtue out of
change or uh any of those things I think
that the change is inevitable it's like
it's not your friend
that doesn't mean you should worship it
the human spirit is a lot more
the fact that we can stand up straight
in the mid and while the winds have
changed but try to blow us and and tear
at us but we stand our spirit stands
firm and straight and does the
impossible
you know against the sands of time
Against The Winds of Change and all that
kind of stuff I think that's what what's
basic about humans and I don't think
it's uh it's about uh
us being in pods
consuming [ __ ]
and there's and history is littered with
people that uh that have individuals
that have done things that basically
have changed the way that we think and
that those things are great I don't
think that that's uh
I think that like we've done a lot of
good
despite
despite the um
the bad Tidings I think that like you
know I think that history is like a is
weird like I think that there's there's
been a lot of bad and and a sort of like
the catalog of massacres and terrible
things but I think that we can get to a
place where we
or we aren't like that and
I kind of think that you know we should
stop over ahead
yeah and because what you're talking
about is you worry where we're heading
but you also there's still hope there
Ariel yeah hope is getting extinguished
by the day but yeah it's it's it's it's
it's pretty much gone now and and and
and I you know I hate to say it I mean
I'll take whatever life gives me I'll go
wherever I wanted if that's China or
Russia then so be it I mean I I will go
I'm sure I'm not going to be I'm going
to be okay and all that kind of stuff I
will be welcome here
so I'll go wherever I wanted that but I
I don't uh
I didn't think it would happen in my in
my lifetime well as in what would happen
in your lifetime oh that I would become
uh you know uh seen as a as some sort of
uh
some sort of danger or harm or that I
did something wrong and that you know
you can just like
punish me and not say anything not not
be no you know I mean it's like whatever
I mean nobody's at fault for whatever
happened to me it's just it's just
uncollateral damage on basically like
just like a mistake Okay and like I get
it but there's no recourse for me and
it's not like I'd rather I'd rather
almost
be found guilty of something do my time
and then get out of jail you know after
a certain this this indefinite kind of
like you know there's no I mean I don't
know if I could get a job at Starbucks
okay like that like they don't let me uh
in certain venues
in La I mean I can't go to concerts I
can't go to restaurants
these are this is my hometown
and there's no explanation I mean is
that legal is that legal I mean does
should I should I no that's not it's not
that it's on Legions that's what the
people think so yeah what are you gonna
do Ariel they don't feel safe with you
there
yeah okay so that's I think it's I think
it's pathetic it is it's a pathetic uh
thing to support I think it's a step uh
it's it's it's once it's pretty much the
end and not pretty much yeah the end of
it's the end of what the old world and
now it's the beginning of the new world
I guess I'm in that limbo state where
it's like semi-denial
semi-morning grief you know like I don't
know what's gonna come but I didn't
think that it was that I didn't think it
was the end well not happy no
I don't know listen man it's been a it's
been really great to discuss this with
us thank you I hope you know that
um you know how much uh I certainly
empathize with what's happened with you
and I I I I really like your
particularly when you talk about cancer
culture I think you're making a very
valid point like this thing you just
said about
I'd rather go to jail and do my time and
come out and be clean is really gets to
the core of some of the issues yeah that
we have with uh this whole thing which
is like it's extrajudicial punishment
it's outside of the legal system it's
meant to get around it and the
consequences are not exactly clear and
no one knows you know when do you come
back and how do you come back and do you
ever get to go to you know your favorite
restaurant or make music and and get it
out
um but maybe it's because I'm a bit more
of an optimist than you I think this
will change
um I think I hope you're right yeah I
think and I also think that you know
there's a reason that you had the
successful music career that you had
which is your very talented musician oh
and there's a reason why this happened
to me and it's the it's like a this is a
uh uh it's a cocoon and I'm and I'm uh
going through metamorphosis yes yeah I
will Blossom yes yes you will that's
exactly yeah that's absolutely and I'm
and I'm I'm St to be somebody at my age
knowing that that can happen still is is
actually a very thing to be helpful for
I just had a kid and I'm extremely into
know
that if you're still filming yes
to know that um
uh to know that uh uh that I that that
I'm experiencing the
the biggest happiness the you know this
the like I mean this is like this is
what it's about this this um to
experience uh the happiness that I feel
it's at the same time while this is all
happening you know but but to have a
daughter and it's like uh I never
thought that that would uh happen at my
age so yeah it's a blessing man uh I
I've got a son uh first one as well
that's similar to your daughter six
months six months it's incredible it's
absolutely incredible which is so much
fun and it's also made me a more
positive person as well because I now
feel a responsibility to actually fight
for the world that I want my children to
grow up in and that's what I wanted to
say is I think this metamorphosis that
you're going through you're gonna come
out of it without the end you'll see the
world with a different vision and you'll
be able to create more of the of the
brilliant work that you've been doing to
this point so I hope so I wish you all
the best man and I really appreciate
your time thank you so if people want to
find you online area where's the best
way to do that
um right now uh yeah you can you can go
to my sub stack I got a sub stack it's
called Uh you just go Ariel Ariel pink
at uh Dot substack.com and you put your
music out on that I'm using it as a
repository for all sorts of unofficial
recordings and stuff like that so it's
uh you know it's just basically a huge
dump that I'm putting on everybody and
you know and it's lots of people have
always been you know lots of it's for
Die Hard fans as well and uh but it's
also for me it's just sort of like a
just just to put it put things out that
I never have and to just sort of
just to sort of give back and shut
people up to uh you know about you know
what I'm doing and stuff like that they
feel like I'm you know just lingering
and feeling sorry for myself I don't
that's not how I I'm always making music
it's just nobody's gonna hear it but no
no
yeah
and tell people as well if you Ariel's
paid subscription if you are so kind but
you don't have to have one necessarily
to hear lots of stuff so all right well
we've got one final question for you and
then we'll ask you a couple of questions
from our supporters uh that only they
will get to see on locals oh great so uh
the final question is always what's the
one thing we're not talking about but we
really should be uh
okay let me think about it I should have
thought about this before okay
um
let me think that there's a the one
thing that we should be talking about
that we should
um
God man
what's that
where is my mind I don't know that's
that's a good thing to talk about yeah
that's that's that's that's listen man
we did a long interview so it doesn't
matter too much do you mind if we do the
audience question of course of course
yeah cool very good we've got anything
to do is sign off to the camera oh [ __ ]
yeah okay
uh
uh Errol thanks so much for coming on
and thank you guys for watching and
listening uh we will be back with
another brilliant interview probably not
quite like this one but brilliant
nonetheless uh uh or raw show all of
them go out at 7pm UK time and for those
of you who like your trigonometry on the
go it's always available as a podcast so
take care and see you soon guys
has your experience with ostracism made
you think less of American society did
it prompt you to consider moving to
Israel or Japan for example
foreign
[Music]